the name comes from well back in the
university I was doing a series of
essays and writing about Sigmund Freud's
idea of the uncanny and I was really
intrigued by this idea of the untimely
it's an essay that Sigmund Freud wrote
about eat a Hoffman's short story called
The Sandman where someone mistakes an
inanimate object for a living breathing
human being and one of the things that
Sigmund Freud really felt was that in
modern life people assigned qualities to
objects around them that may not exist
there whatsoever so they call this the
uncanny and he also referred to cities
as well like the idea of walking through
the city and the way the urban landscape
could lead you with to a sense of
disorientation and to a kind of you know
sense of repetition in the way of city
can unfold as you walk so stuff like
that it was basically meant to be like
when you press play and there's nobody
there
first and foremost one I was never
planning on doing this as a long-term so
spooky I was in college it was a fun
name it thought it was you know just a
fun thing when you say what's the
difference between me and my stage name
the idea is that as a musician you
always think of yourself as inhabiting a
certain cultural space and the kind of
cultural landscape so when I say
cultural space what I mean to imply
there is that you exist within certain
parameters of how people think of
culture downtown New York I'm within
certain styles of music and I'm also
within certain cultural you know and
literary context so DJ Spooky was meant
to be a kind of ironic take on that it
was always meant to be kind of a
criticism and critique of how downtown
culture would separate genres and styles
because it was ambiguous he couldn't fit
it into anything and that was the point
it's like the iPod playlist has killed
the way we think of the normal album so
let's think of this as just saying you
take you go into a record store and all
those categories and all those different
ways of segregating music have been
thrown out the window so the difference
between myself in real life and that is
a I'm the opposite I usually am very
specific about how I engage information
how I engage people what contexts I'm
engaging and above all the research that
goes into each of those so one the DJ
Spooky's a lot you know the sort of
wilder persona and then Paul Miller is
more of a nuts and bolts kind of person
meaning just making sure all these
things work
well let's look back at the history of
the idea of the record in my book sound
unbound we traced the guy who actually
came up with the main concept for the
graphic design of the record cover
sleeve his name's Alex Stein wise and
one of the things in my book that we
really tried to figure out was the
revolution in graphic design that
occurred when people put images on album
covers now if you think about the 20th
century and the idea of visual visual
vocabulary the album occupies a really
important space in the cultural
landscape and above all they try this
experiment one day go in a record store
and just try and guess what the music
sounds like by looking at the album
cover you'll get this kind of
psychological relationship to the
imagery of the music but that idea is
translated to iPhone apps is translated
to the small you know kind of icons on
your computer you name it the idea of a
visual icon that gives you a sense of
information very quickly and that you
can easily just say that's what the
style is that's something that I think
record coverage sleeves really led
towards but at the same time the album
as we know it didn't come into being
until mainly after the world Second
World War
because record labels realized they'd be
able to make a lot more money putting
all the singles of an artist onto one
album and selling the whole album as a
kind of a concept so by the time the
sixties rolled in that became a huge art
form in its own right with bands like
the Beatles and The Rolling Stones and
Hendrix the total concept album same
thing with Pink Floyd now if you
fast-forward to the 70s and Grandmaster
Flash Afrika Bambaataa DJ Kool Herc
Grandmaster Caz all these guys that were
essentially like the DNA of what we're
doing now one of the main thing that
differentiates them from artists before
is that they made albums based on the
fact that they didn't care about the
band as in a kind of thing in its own
right they cared about manipulating the
recording and that became the album
usually bands would make a song to
record for an album but what happens
with the DJ's you say well the album is
everything we need thanks band you can
go away no you know you don't really
need the band or the singer/songwriter
in the same way so you look at
everything as part of your palette when
you think about a composer
you know like vogner or pierre boulez or
something like that most of the issues
of composers working with they're about
Crete notated music that someone else
will play but if I take that person and
play them as a record I'm becoming not
only a conductor and composer of collage
but at the same time I'm looking at a
whole layer of what goes into copyright
law who owns those memories who owns the
way that that sound gets remixed and
transformed and above all how much fun
it is to actually just mess with other
people's stuff it's so yeah I like I
like the idea of it it's a trickster
motif you know like you're you're kind
of just messing around with people's
memories of songs
that myths of the near future give
people the ability to really kind of
explore the present so say for example
if you look at William Gibson and his
book Neuromancer or if you look at a JG
Ballard or Samuel Delaney those are
probably three of my favorite writers in
that genre
all of them project slightly to the near
future as a way of talking about the
current moment and I think science
fiction and sound is a really
interesting thing you might as well
think of it as sonic fiction when you're
coming up with different ways of getting
old memories to transform you're
scratching you're doing all this kind of
sampling what ends up happening is that
you're becoming a kind of writer with
sound in fact if you look at the root
word of phonograph it just means
phonetics of graphology phonograph
writing with sound so graphology you
know graffiti same root word phone etics
you know speech all this kind of stuff
phonograph simple but when you unpack
the meaning it actually kind of expands
out and that's what I was going for my
book sound unbound we should try and get
people to figure out how do we unpack
some of the meanings that go into these
kinds of sonically coated landscapes so
yeah science fiction or sonic fiction I
kind of like punting on that
figure out was okay in contemporary 21st
century life the alienation between the
self and the land around you or the self
and even the urban landscape you name
them most people walk around with
headphones on they're barely
encountering or dealing with their
fellow person
or if they're in a car they're in this
kind of cocoon stuck in suburban
rush-hour traffic or something the
landscape of the their current
experiences is just really
compartmentalized you know and what I
wanted to do with Antarctica was say
let's hit the reset button on that and
see what happens to your creative
process let's go to the most remote
place that you can imagine set up a
studio and see what music comes out of
it so I took a studio down to several of
the main ice fields and the basic idea
was to give myself four weeks and these
ice fields to create a new work let's
see what happens and you know it was
really important to me to kind of think
about the urban landscape on one hand
versus this hyper you know abstract ice
landscape on the other and article one
of the things that was so remark about
it was that the ice itself is a kind of
pure geometry so say for example if I
was facing someone wearing a I don't
know a Joy Division t-shirt with the
mountains on it or something like that
seeing that as a computer abstraction
versus actually going to these
continents and seeing a 40-mile chunk of
ice break off to the size of mountains
this sense of scale was just
awe-inspiring I mean just um I remember
one time it took several hours to walk
out into a major glacier field off the
Weddell icy shelf that's w e-- d de l l
Weddell I see all right so if you this
is Antarctic summer if you fall in the
water you die in about two minutes so
you're walking the ice is creaking the
landscape is like subtly you know
shifting and if anyone out there has
ever been in an earthquake this is like
kind of a slow-motion earthquake but the
land is shifting and droning and
creaking and you know if you ever walk
on ice and you're like whoa you could
fall through you really you know put you
in that language we're at very cautious
you know mentality so
the physicality of that and the just the
shared lack of urban noise and machinery
just the wind the water and your breath
you know that kind of thing that was
pure poetry
and you know I treasure that it was just
I can only wonder what astronauts must
feel like or something like that when
you're really in the space of silence
and you are feeling and breathing in a
way that you're really aware of your
muscle and bone and the breath and the
body and the movement and all those
things that just you take for granted in
the urban landscape felt like on one
hand the clarity of thought was amazing
but on the other and we didn't we went
during the Antarctic summer so the Sun
didn't set the whole time we were there
I was permanent afternoon and when I say
permanent afternoon you know I'm talking
like crystal clear crispy blue sky all
of a sudden you really didn't need to
sleep as much because it just was
difficult and how that translated into
my creative process I'm I'm still am not
quite sure but it it made my
relationship to sleep a kind of abstract
you know bizarre I can't put my finger
on it but my ended up dreaming very
intense dreams because I only needed
about four hours of sleep meanwhile we
take you know four to eight our hikes
way out into these you know kind of
glaciers and so on you know all day and
you come back and you'd be tired and you
still couldn't sleep because the Sun was
up and it felt like you know it's like
2:00 in the afternoon or something even
if it was midnight so yeah
Korky sleep is crucial and I tend to
find when the sun is shining I find it
much more difficult to get that sense of
obviously
what I'm going forward with the string
arrangements for my Antarctic symphony
is a pun here on one hand you have a
string quartet which is not a symphony
when and on the other hand is you have
me sampling them and making it sound
like there's many more people playing so
the whole notion of kind of sampling
applied to classical music is very
intriguing to me because composers
throughout history have borrowed motifs
and quotes from one another so Bach
Beethoven Duke Ellington Thelonious Monk
these are all people who would sort of
rearrange or take riffs from people
same thing with rock if you look at the
Rolling Stones during a cover of Otis
Redding or you know if you look at
literature James Joyce is pulling
fragments of text from other people
so the antartic symphony has a geometric
relationship to the landscape it's
saying that this landscape and the
minimal kind of yeah I'm talking like
seeing ice is visually very kind of
early minimal but there's a complexity
and layering that goes on with this kind
of thing so the music is is slightly
repetitive and when I say we repetitive
it's in the same traditions people like
Steve Reich or Erik sati or even Debussy
so what I wanted to do was kind of
invoke that and then dive into that kind
of repetition as a DJ thing because
detain you here be it's like boom boom
boom bap bap
you know hip hop house techno so how do
you translate between those electronic
motifs and the motifs of the landscape
itself that's what I wanted to go for
Antarctica is one of the most remote and
beautiful places on earth I don't think
that everyone should go there I also
think that we need to respect it as an
extent of a of a National Park for the
planet like it should be you know put in
parentheses you know in the sentence of
humanity this place needs to be a
parenthesis and when I say parentheses
mean I'm talking like you go around it
like you know leave it alone let it
exist and when I want people to see with
this film is not only a respect for this
place from the bottom of my heart I'm
talking like just the beauty but at the
same time to get people to realize that
we should treasure it maybe visualize it
but leave it alone and it's there's a
sense of awe and with these huge
landscapes and the open spaces maybe
someone living out in the Mid American
deep Midwest desert can you imagine the
same thing or somebody living in Namibia
or the Arctic is very different but yeah
just awe of the landscape I know this
sounds like nerdy and corny and stuff
like that but you know let it be nerdy
in a corny it's beautiful place I could
just sit on an isolation and just watch
the land for like days months years yeah
I'd say most of my work is just trying
to make sense of the disorienting and
overloaded world that we inhabit we're
bombarded with sound at every level
sound if you look at bats
you know the navigate was sonar there's
like you know they're very precise they
can even see it back head towards a
building in to swerve way but you'll see
a bird that doesn't you know smash right
into a glass window it's very funny you
know anybody out there's probably seen
that it's like oh it's terrible I guess
have you ever in in a skyscraper and you
see a bird just flies right into the
side of a window whales for example also
navigate with sound but they're now
beginning to be beached because the
oceans getting too noisy weird things
like that I mean this is very real but
if you look at the satellites in the sky
at night you know it's an eerie sense of
weird you know we're in a planet
surrounded by certain kinds of
frequencies and noise the Earth's
magnetic sphere makes weird sounds the
Sun you know the heart of our solar
system makes noise even interstellar
phenomena like black holes you know
people have study them and you know a
black hole can emit sounded like Ranger
20,000 doctors below b-flat you know I
mean that's a lot that's a very low tone
so yeah what how do I think of my
environment and what happens with sound
art I love to play with the idea of
elusive and intangible things that could
be psychological it could be perceptual
it could be just the way your ears help
you just navigate around it try as an
experiment closing your eyes and
navigating with the ears it's eerie
because walls you can actually hear your
footstep maybe bounce off of or you can
feel the vibration of your voice and
help that use that to navigate so sound
art I'm always intrigued with how little
we use of other senses and we just
prioritize the eyes and you just want to
see everything and navigate you know the
art world is similar that I wish people
would use their ears a lot more
my film rebirth of a nation amusing
enough was a component in a show I had
at Paula Cooper gallery and one of the
things that really goes into my mind
when I think about contemporary art and
music is how weirdly divided they are
the art world likes music sort of but
when they do they usually go for sort of
like all white bread art rock they don't
get it you'll never see hip hop in
normal Whitney Biennial or whatever I
mean they don't the art wall has
problems with rhythm now at the same
time you have really interesting
electronic music and multicultural
specifically multicultural takes on
contemporary art my film rebirth of a
nation was a critique of the way Bush
had gotten into office playing off of
racial politics and the fears that
White's have of being becoming a
minority and I think the code words for
the Bush administration people like Karl
Rove was that states rights and
devolution of federal powers would make
these kind of white now all of a sudden
you notice with the Obama administration
they're having a rise of all these white
militias and stuff like that
yeah I mean white Americans feel anxiety
about some of the issues and I think
that that needs to be addressed Birth of
a Nation the film by DW Griffith's is
one of the most important films in
American history it set the tone for how
America just views racial politics in
cinema so I got the rights to the film
we remixed it when I say we I guess well
me and the whole idea was to apply DJ
technique to film in a way that kind of
self implode the film and get people to
think about it as a you know maybe
something that needs to be looked at a
lot more closely so with Bush you have
to remember they played games with the
black vote they disenfranchised a large
amount of people by playing those games
and again it was a lot of it happen in
the old south where places like Ohio so
Birth of a Nation was the first film to
show a flawed election and in 1915 I
mean you know a lot of games were being
played with the black vote so
disenfranchisement blackface you know if
you fast-forward and update it you could
easily see the same residents with
avatar where most of the main characters
were in blue face those were black
actors for example or Jar Jar Binks this
annoying creature that's like a minstrel
on the Star Wars thing
racial politics is still very much
prevailing an American film Terminator
or you know what's the Transformers
where they have the kind of minstrel
robots who had this annoying black sort
of almost gave voice or something when I
said yeah I'm not no disrespect I'm just
saying it's a minstrel kind of damask
elated male voice where they're always
making black character like a Jar Jar
Binks and annoying yeah what's up y'all
yeah you know it's kind of very annoying
creature or something like that that has
a high-pitched and like yeah really
annoying like you know so anyway Birth
of a Nation
what makes this Antarctic project
different than that is they're both
critiques of the nation-states
relationship to the individual
Antarctica is the only place on earth
with no government it's the only place
that really says you are you the
subjectivity that goes into that we want
you step off a boat and you're on an ice
field in the middle of nowhere
you are without the idea of the
nation-state anymore and I think birth
of a nation obviously nation you know
nationalism nation state the
environmental politics that go into how
nations play with carbon trading how
nations play with the idea of pollution
and all these kinds of things you could
say that the divisions now are even more
encoded because if the north/south
divide like the industrialized nations
of the north versus the more
multicultural countries of like China
India Russia
well Russia's it's still considered
European but if you go slightly outside
of you know there's plenty of Russians
that look very Asian
so the racial politics that go into
environmental issues is something that's
hangs like a Spectre over a lot of the
process right now so I had a big gallery
show at Robert Miller gallery called
north-south there was a pun about my
birth of a nation versus Antarctica
sense of humor in the title but
nonetheless I'm very concerned about the
way environmental politics shapes out
with industrialized versus non
industrialized nations something really
we have to think about
yeah I mean I think we're really in the
crisis of 21st century culture is
standardization on one hand that's a
crisis precisely because it really flat
lines and dis deadens a lot of this
amazing stuff but on the other hand as
the next couple years kick in you're
gonna be seeing what I like to call mass
customization where everyone can have
you know their phone or their iPad or
whatever but they're going to pull it
into their own orbit in their own way
and they're pulling material that's out
there in the world as their own
vocabulary they didn't I didn't make
this phone you know but I've customized
and transformed it so I'm always
intrigued with saying that nothing stays
the same in this era in the 20th century
you know someone like you know Ford they
would say you know what you can have any
color car you want as long as it's black
you know they had the whole sense of
humor about the the production line all
making the Model T Ford car there was
the exact same machine rolling off the
lund now that was amazing because it was
high tech at that time but for the 21st
century where we could just retrofit and
reboot anything why stick to one thing I
mean just always transform and change
everything that's the DJ model as well
so by customizing and transforming it
adds new life to I think the way we
function right now when I say the way we
function I'm talking about going down
the street walking you know around
everyone has a little computer which is
essentially as a cell phone most people
I'm sorry you know it's there there's a
class division here but even in
economically you know low-income and so
on most people have some kind of
communications device and I think it's
transformed the way the world works
right now and this is just the beginning
so within the next five to seven years
there'll be seeing probably a massive
revolution and getting rid of sameness
and just having this wildly creative and
inventive era
um I'd say my audience is pretty much
anyone who thinks which is a big
audience and luckily and happily people
have been very supportive of the idea of
a writer artist musician making
conceptual music I'm not art Rock I mean
art rock had dominates in the art world
I'm a kind of insurgency like an
electronic music insurgency because I'm
trying to push a lot of boundaries
simultaneously racial politics economic
politics and above all the psychology
about how people assigned criteria and
value and what people say is cool or
good I love the idea that you know your
cell phone is disrupting the entire sort
of consumer pattern of people or I love
the idea that you know what a curator or
a museum director or some art dealer the
value isn't for them to create it's the
value that we each of us bring to
something so it's disruptive of all this
kind of top-down hierarchies of how
power forms in you know the normal
corporate model of this artist or this
book or but about so my book is turning
the world of Martha Stewart and Oprah
Winfrey upside down and saying you know
you are the mix I enjoy writing and it's
one another weird thing a deef I have
with normal critics is that like why
don't you just do the music man you know
you know I'm like look I'm an artist I'd
like to write I also do music so they're
not separate to me music is writing
writing is art art is music simple
in massive volumes I can see as it again
as a DJ you have to be a current and
keep aware of what's going on and that
means you know just massive amounts of
information so a DJ is a kind of
obsessive about information I tend to
think that if you look at Michael
Jackson
he's the quad of the King of Pop precise
because he had millions and millions of
people listen to the same record or same
songs if you play Billie Jean for
example everybody knows that even in
India or Nepal or the most remote parts
of Timbuktu you know people know that
song so millions of people listen up
I'm the opposite where it's like set of
millions of people listen to the same
song it's millions of songs being
scratched and sliced and diced and you
have to keep track of it all so it's
like the information ocean or data cloud
you know just you know there's I think
iTunes now has passed its bill several
billion download you know think of all
those people it's the biggest record
store in the world and amazingly enough
to me again as a DJ an artist the
top-selling album of all time right now
is the blank CD you know so you know
it's number one on every chart
um I'm a big Pro open-source Pro
Creative Commons kind of artist I think
that it's important to realize that
copyright laws as it's written relates
mainly to the 18th century's
relationship to physical goods and as
things move more and more into a digital
media hyper-connected world we need to
transform the models of how we think of
ownership copyright law is something I
respect but the way the law is written
versus the way we live and this rip
makes Byrne kind of scenario you know
it's all about I think thinking of
digital music as the kind of new folk
culture where everyone should share and
by sharing they create a more rich and
robust you know narrative
yeah sure but I get value out of that
I get a different kind of value you get
branding you get advertising you get
word at the mouth viral marketing yeah
you know you can't you couldn't pay for
that